Atlantis as Columbus set sail voyage of
science to the space station that is a
February 2008 launch of space shuttle
Atlantis a crew included NASA astronaut
Leland Melvin one of just over 550
people ever to travel to space but
Melvin's path into orbit sets him apart
you could say it was a standout wide
receiver at the University of Richmond
the Droid Lions chose him in the 1986
NFL Draft that makes him the only person
in history to be drafted by pro football
team and fly in space
Evan tells his remarkable story in this
new book chasing space an astronaut
story of grit Grace and second chances
is also available in a young readers
edition Leland melton great to have you
here
great to be here thank you so let's just
start with the obvious I mean how did
you do this oh my goodness was a lot of
people that had my back when I failed in
my mother mother and father always told
me you can do anything you put your mind
to and so when I went to NASA you know I
was working at NASA and a friend of mine
said you'd be a great astronaut like
yeah right and then another friend of
mine got into the astronaut corps and I
told myself well if that knucklehead can
get it I can get it I applied after he
got in and I got in but you never
thought you could be an astronaut
because you said you didn't see it at
black astronaut growing right 69 Neil
and Buzz walking to the moon these buzz
cut sight that wasn't me I want to be
Arthur Ashe he trained right down the
street from where I lived in Lynchburg
Virginia on Pierce Street by dr. Worrell
Dwayne Johnson and so he had character
he was intelligent he was athletic he
was a great person I wanted to be him
much admired American but science was a
favorite subject of yours as a child
right well because my mother gave me a
chemistry set there was non OSHA
certified agent appropriate and I create
an explosion in her living room and that
activated my brain to be a scientist but
I loved I love one of your favorite
entries in your journals is take
extravagant pleasure listen to that take
extravagant pleasure in being alive when
you're up there you said nothing really
prepares you for what you see once
you're up in space yeah you see these
colors of the Caribbean I mean you
almost need new definitions of blue to
describe these colors as your indigo
you know and it's just turquoise and
these coral reefs
you know brimming with life and I just
it just kind of blew my mind but on your
path to becoming an Astra you had a very
bad hearing ear injury and they told you
look you will never be able to get into
space yeah the doctor said you will
never fly because we don't know what
happened to you I was in a training
accident in the six million gallon pool
and they forgot to put this little pad
in my helmet that would allow me to
clear my ears and when I was going to
the different memorial services for the
Columbia crew the chief flight surgeon
watch me clear my ears as we took off
the landed and he signed me a waiver to
fly because he said I believe in you no
but it's more than that I mean you have
to have some skills you have to have
well then you'll be rich they say it's
one of the hardest dollars to get
through you got a lot going for you in
terms of the raw skills that are
necessary well I think the the football
training in the NFL you know that
teamwork that dedication that discipline
you know you know the hard practices
coming back from those hard practices
and continuing to to play is something
that helped model the astronaut training
program because it was long days many
years and you know it's been a while
since we sent a man to the moon right
the young generation doesn't necessarily
understand or appreciate NASA one of
your missions is to make them understand
my mission is to take the experiences
that I had in space seeing this
incredible planet going around every 90
minutes in the sunrise and sunset every
45 and bring that down to the classroom
so the kids can say wow I can do that in
fact that guy it looks kind of like me
maybe I can be an astronaut and that's
why I give them these patches astronauts
steam Explorer science technology
engineering arts and mathematics so they
can be or do anything you get to take
stuff in space with you what did you
take oh I took my mom and dad's wedding
ring nice
I took a baseball cap from the
University of Richmond in a Curious
George book Curious George VI's Vienna
that was my guy you know you kept me it
got me in trouble here is George was
your guy a little into the code in
Curious George those were my favorite
books too yeah Leland Melvin wonderful
to have you here thank you so much thank
you so much and chasing space is on sale
and you can hear more of our CBS this
morning on our podcast find extended
interviews and podcast originals on
iTunes and Apple's podcast app